in 2008 Paul Krugman won the Nobel Prize
in Economics isn't it time he gets
another remember what he said way back
on election day quote it really does now
look like President Donald J Trump and
markets are plunging when might we
expect them to recover a first pass
answer is never
that's pretty awesome for a garden gnome
but he's no garden gnome he's a Nobel
prize-winning economist a garden gnome
could run circles around this bearded
Butthead and every time he gets it wrong
he gets a raise so he must be loaded now
as a stock market broke 23,000 and
filings for unemployment benefits
plunged to the lowest level since 1973
so will Pauly admit how wrong he was
I doubt it look at him but simply so
many would rather see the economy crash
that admit Trump's made it great
just like those who'd rather ignore the
defeat of Isis than admit Trump's direct
approach worked or that it's straight
talk of North Korea has finally gotten
China to act but the Krugman's of the
world see Trump behind every rainy day
after all just weeks ago Krugman blamed
Trump for a non-existent cholera
outbreak in Puerto Rico he deserves
another prize for that too or a pink
slip bottom line so many in the media
have made a mint out of picking at
wounds stories about kneeling oppression
division phone calls but turn off that
noise for a minute and ask yourself has
America changed much since the election
as the economy grows and Isis dies yes
it got better you know I was thinking
you know he is so wrong Krugman is so
wrong he deserves another another Nobel
Prize Dana so me and Sean created an
application video to the Nobel Committee
poor Krugman featuring his greatest
comment roll it if we discovered that
you know space aliens were planning to
attack and we needed a massive buildup
to counter the the space alien threat
and really inflation and budget deficits
took secondary place to that this slump
would be over in 18 months by 2005 or so
it will
become clear that the Internet's impact
on the economy has been no greater than
the fax machines cholera in a u.s.
territory among US citizens in the 21st
century heck of a job Trumpy okay
cholera not confirmed conjunctivitis yes
I and those of like mind have been right
about everything
Dana well done Brian our College
Association and Sean O'Rourke I have one
thing to say sure nobody said last week
about tax reform what all lives you know
take this segment Reid Craig Minh and
you decide he say he's gonna get
promoted over this you know he will get
another price you know on the Dow has
reached a new 1000 point milestone five
times since Trump's been elected its hit
on new high 51 times you have to you
must be you're looking at your 401 K and
you're going thank God for Trump
[Laughter]
I plan to sail away any day you guys
show a star yeah you're just like slap
each other on the back but the thing
that I didn't like about your otherwise
brilliant talking points as you said
Trump gets all the credit and I think to
myself wait a second Greg such a smart
guy I would say you know what Krugman is
wrong about Krugman and a lot of people
said Trump gets elected it destabilizes
the economy markets don't like
instability the markets will go down to
the contrary Trump gets elected people
say hey wait a minute
guess what says my stockbroker this
guy's gonna go after regulations he's
gonna cut taxes you better get in now
okay the market goes up Krugman wrong
there but but let's end there but why
why then do you say Trump gets credit
when in fact the credit would be Trump
has not destabilized the murk cuz he
hasn't done anything he hasn't cut taxes
he hasn't done tax reform and he you
know so people are saying like Oh Wells
smooth-sailing we can keep the Obama
policies phantoms but you know what
he hasn't built a wall yet yet we're
watching immigration go down it's all
about he is he is the wall
weatherman every day he comes out on
television like that he says you know
what it's gonna be clear skies and sunny
and every day it's pouring rain yeah
yeah he still has a job and everybody
still listens to him but that's why the
media hires people like Krugman once
you're right in the mainstream media no
one cares about your track record they'd
rather you be left and wrong than right
and right and they've been wrong about
Trump from the jump they said it wasn't
gonna win the primary they said he was
only in it to sell hats and to boost the
apprentice ratings and they said he
wasn't gonna win the general then they
said after he won the general he was
gonna leave office and give it to pence
so I don't know why we listen to these
people anymore they said he was going to
cause World War three they said we'd
never see 3% GDP growth they said he'd
never defeat Isis they said everything
and it was wrong yeah you know Kimberly
and they said it's impossible Q's for
him to win and electoral college he
accused Trump of causing cholera and
then goes oh well conjunctivitis
New York Times immediately you just got
got all of his stuff in a cardboard box
and sent him on the street dictionary
yes guy pointment or something yeah look
but this is no surprise again they can't
admit the truth and cover the facts and
give credit where credit is due so you
know this is one thing after the next as
it relates to President Trump they're
not going to give him any credit why
would they do that they're already baked
in in terms of their mindset their
opinion of him and you just be fair be
fair be honest and you don't he was be
looking to go and put the nail in and
try to just like okay this is my story
this is what I'm staying with and how
can we tie this and make this a story
about how bad President Trump is amen
all right